[Musique]
le
style d'agriculture de la ferme familiale est vraiment en train de
disparaître. Le producteur de rouge à lèvres vient de darren von
roden en
quelque sorte quelle extension nous voyons au
cours des quatre dernières années, nous avons eu environ 25
pour cent
de nos fermes laitières dans l'état du
wisconsin ont  gagné le passage séculaire des affaires
seulement 2 350
fermes les fermes laitières ont fait
faillite à
partir du sol
[Musique]
je suis un vrai capitaliste j'ai horreur du
socialisme
john charles division
toutes ces filles de ce côté elles
viennent d'avoir leurs
leurs bébés donald  atout sur l'affaire
vice-président mike pence lisa
étranger c'est le nœud de l'accord c'est pour
nous donner un
meilleur accès au marché canadien
aussi je suis d'accord avec le fait que
la personnalité exubérante du
secrétaire d'atout je n'aime pas vraiment ses
tweets et
et  quoi d'autre, mais je pense qu'il comprend
que c'est ainsi qu'il communique avec certaines
personnes
darren van roden président
regarde la quantité de lait que le nouvel
accord autorise au canada
est vraiment d'environ trois  jours de production
dans l'état du wisconsin
le fait que vous voyez des signes de biden par
exemple une indication que les
zones rurales sont un peu plus équilibrées
qu'elles n'avaient été
suspectes à la production politique américaine et
adaptée locale cela n'a pas trop d'
importance
j'attends  Donald Trump réussit assez bien
dans les zones rurales ici, la seule
question est de se présenter en grand nombre pour
lui ou sont-ils moins
satisfaits, les gens biden se présenteront-ils
[Musique]
écoutez
ce qui rend l'Amérique formidable, c'est le
capitalisme de la concurrence et celui qui peut travailler le
plus dur  et travailler le plus intelligemment
réalise le meilleur le parti démocrate
a une plate-forme et ils veulent s'assurer
que l'agriculture familiale s'efforce et se
développe dans ce pays
où nous ne voyons pas cela des
républicains
[Musique]
pour darren van roden le mote de
villegricol  na padav nirzini patras
pendant ce temps
génération génération